I mean that's that's what is so
mind-blowing about this 85 South
I don't recall - oh it's like a movement
it's like a revolution like the impact
that 85 South is making not just on the
comedy game but like entertainment it's
like unfounded what you guys are
achieving and I've talked to Chad the
producer and Carlos and Clayton we're
like what is your take on 85 South and
why it is having the impact that it has
one because it's genuine this is a
genuine relationship that we have like
fly came in what two seasons after we
came in but he fit right in and and just
when we communicated with each other it
was just always genuine so that's the
basis of it okay but one of the major
things that I think it is I mean a hotel
lobby right now we are no this is the
mud this is the come out this is the
hotel excited you know you guys went
from like the studios the trap yeah and
that's the thing like the only way that
that can happen is just if it's genuine
you have to be excited about going to do
whatever it is you're going to do and
one of the major things I think that
makes what we do a little different is
that we all hold our own in our own
right I got shows in Atlanta this
weekend DC was in Pittsburgh last week I
mean just yesterday Carlos is in
Cincinnati Ohio headlining the funny
bone all weekend so we all do what we do
individually but we come together and
get on stage together you know kings of
comedy is a legendary movie because you
imagine if we got to sort you got to CDL
you know I mean say it Bernie and Steve
come out together and talk [__] together
that's a whole nother movie right you
know so I think that's really what gives
people the different feel you've never
seen it done that way before and it's
all improv does it be magic to us to
like we don't practice anything we get
on stage and we go you know I mean we
got my man Craig right here I'm gonna
attest to that we never sit around and
have no meetings about I
we in this city so this what we got none
of that because it's so genuine and like
I said that energy that I was talking
about it's so strong and it's so genuine
that when we get on stage it's literally
magic so I think that most people can
see that and even the people who may
have negative opinions about what we do
because you know you see all of that it
doesn't that doesn't matter you know I
mean because that is the same type of
effect that the positive energy has even
though you don't like it it's affected
you some type of way and what it is that
we do has made you feel real emotion so
that means it's something special I
heard somebody say there Martin one
funny the other day I looked at him like
they was crazy but he was able to sit
and have a conversation to me as to why
he didn't which means you watched it
long enough to develop the opinion that
you had so it really doesn't change in
regards to the what I'm giving you or
what what Martin did in regards to
giving you that show he gave it to you
and because he gave it to you he was
able to formulate something that lasted
for long after he stopped doing it and
still have people having conversations
about it right now and that's the type
of energy that we create with the 85
like god forbid if we was to stop
tomorrow the things that we've done up
until this point I feel like would be
talked about for a long time because
people haven't even really grasped the
reality of it like to go back and watch
like these guys that really doing
something completely different so I just
think that the reason why we're able to
you know do what we do not necessarily
the success because that just came
organically but the reason why we're
able to do what we do is because it was
just based in a genuine Iza we brothers
for real you know I mean we don't sit
around and talk about work we talk about
life you know I mean like we know each
other's children families I've been to
these people's house and hug their
mothers you know I mean like all of us
you know it's just a different type of
environment and for us to be able to
have that type of Brotherhood and still
be able to get on stage and share the
light it's amazing and the eighty five
percenters
definitely reflect that yeah they
serious you know I mean and in there is
it's in this it's it's crazy to me
because you know all around is just a
blessing man it's just a super blessing
because like I said like we've been
talking about this whole time my
perspective is different in losest
perspective is different lies
perspective is different so a lot of the
things that will probably cause
dissension or cause disruption amongst
this process just doesn't affect us the
same way I've seen people you know we
work in all different types of
environments I've seen how opinions
affect people I've seen people really
look at comments that people leave and
be truly like deflated right there's no
way I can be deflated about anybody's
opinion you are entitled to your opinion
but I'm entitled not to give a [__]
about you know I mean and that's whether
it be whatever it may be but none of us
allow what they say quote unquote to
affect what we do you know I'm saying
I'm gonna be me regardless of whether or
not you like it or not you don't have to
like it but until you decide to get up
and do something that's gonna stop me
from doing what I do you gonna have to
just keep not liking it but I've seen
the people that do like it you guys are
like the Beatles out there yeah I mean
no it's that's the baby or anything the
people who do love it like that's
something no I'd like to look at life in
the regards to this you don't have to
know what you want you just have to know
what you don't want and don't like so as
long as you knows you don't like you're
good the love the only matter like that
goes without saying because that isn't
what somebody's gonna need motivation on
so I don't even like to even really
discuss those type of things because you
don't need no motivation on how to deal
with love but the negative stuff and I
hate that comedians and entertainers get
is what I see deflate them so offer I
can offer any type of perspective it'll
be based on that because the love is the
love you don't need no preparation for
love
love is love and whenever you get it she
won't know it's love
I had a dude in the mall walk up on me
man literally she go no you knew my
appreciation bro I'm walking away with
an eight and it's like you don't have to
prepare for that no I mean that doesn't
take any preparation because you're able
to receive that however you receive it
but it's the other stuff that you have
to prepare yourself for the stuff that
you don't want so once you prepare
yourself for the stuff that you don't
want everything that you want just
becomes that much more magnified because
the things you don't want don't affect
your ability to recognize the things
that you do mm-hmm
and the the come up as will land this
plane here it one thing that helps
communes keep perspective is like
bombing on stage and I asked every
comedian on here like a story of getting
booed or like just an unforgettable show
they were just everything went wrong
right like do you have one top of mine
that and this is how crazy it happens
for me okay is that unique I am as a
human being